[Music]
on this wednesday night
fresh cash for classrooms the feds
finally pony up billions for
back-to-school
pandemic basics when you show up five
weeks late with your assignment
you don't expect an a plus why
substitute teachers
feel forgotten breaking news a boycott
in the nba
over the police shooting of jacob lake
as wisconsin's protests
turned deadly hundreds of thousands in
hurricane laura's path
don't doubt 9-1-1 no one's gonna answer
okay and you are on your own
warnings about an unsurvivable storm
surge
and the next act there are people in the
future
who need us the movie that theaters hope
will produce
profits
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
robin gill good evening and thank you
for joining us
in less than two weeks most schools
across canada are scheduled to reopen
students in yukon have already resumed
classwork
while reopening plans vary from province
to province the concerns don't it's
become a source of anxiety for parents
across the country
and a flash point for tensions between
teachers unions
and some provincial governments the big
question what will classroom life look
like in our newly sanitized
physically distanced world today the
prime minister pledged
2 billion dollars in back-to-school
funding to help provinces and
territories ensure that kids can safely
return to class
there's an additional 112 million
dollars for schools
in first nations communities justin
trudeau says the goal is to ease
parents fears our children
must be safe in the classroom that's
non-negotiable
no parent should be losing sleep because
they have to go back to work
but aren't confident schools are
properly prepared
critics say the money should have come
weeks ago let's bring in our chief
political correspondent david aiken with
more on the funding announcement david
will the cash get to schools in time
no it really won't robin as you
mentioned schools already started in the
yukon
tomorrow school starts in quebec in the
french public system
other provinces coming online as early
as monday next week
between september 1st and the 15th most
schools will be online
so what the federal government has done
here is they've set up what the
government calls
the safe return to class fund which is
as you mentioned a two billion dollar
pool of money
it's going to be distributed on a per
capita basis to
provincial and territorial governments
almost no strings attached
trudeau said the money can be used as
provinces and school boards see fit
but these are funds that some have been
pressing for
since july any announcement that comes
today will be welcome
but when you show up five weeks late
with your assignment you don't expect an
a
now what what do we expect the provinces
to spend the money on
well probably on temporary items
additional school buses
more masks for kids remote learning
tools
but provinces are reluctant to spend
this one-time boost from the feds
on anything permanent more teachers for
example and that's because
provinces would then be stuck with those
higher costs
permanently also half of the money
announced today
will not be distributed until later this
fall
and half will be distributed early in
the new year
robin okay given that fact does this
feel like a campaign announcement to you
yes it did uh the premiers did not ask
for this funding
they first got wind of it on monday and
were officially told about it just
yesterday
when the pm held a first minister's
teleconference now the premiers are
happy to have the extra cash don't get
me wrong but
the idea of ottawa spending money on
education something that is clearly a
provincial responsibility
well that idea came from liberal mps or
at least that's what the pm said and so
yes
this felt very much like extra insurance
something liberals can talk about on the
campaign
trail in the albeit unlikely event that
the trudeau liberals
lose a confidence vote this fall robin
david aiken in ottawa thanks david the
ontario government has released its plan
for dealing with covet 19 outbreaks
within schools
anyone who tests positive for kova 19
will be required to isolate for 14 days
if the virus was acquired outside of the
school the patient's entire cohort will
likely be required
to self-isolate as well this includes
groups that may be in contact while on
the bus or during after school programs
if there are two or more cases linked
within a 14-day period
that would be considered an outbreak
school boards can then determine
if the school needs to be closed we're
not taking
any chances our kids belong in school
they belong in the classroom with the
guidance of their dedicated teachers
in the benefit of being around kids
their own age
and we are prepared to do whatever it
takes to protect them
british columbia has approved back to
school plans for all of the province's
60 school districts today our ministry
and schools across bc are taking the
best
science-based public health advice and
planning to have
as many children as possible back in
classrooms in september
details of each back-to-school plan vary
by district due to differences in school
space scheduling issues public feedback
and staff collective agreements but the
ministry has already determined that
students will be taught in learning
cohorts of between 60 and 120 students
and that masks will be mandatory for
older students and staff in high traffic
areas
many of canada's substitute teachers
feel they've been left out of back to
school plans
with gova 19 expected to cause more
illness and absences this year
substitutes may be needed more than ever
before but as heather york's west
explains there are also fears these
teachers who work in different schools
could help the virus spread school
under covid19 is about to look very
different
inside this calgary catholic school
desks are spaced out some sinks and
fountains have been blocked off
and arrows show which way students can
walk down the halls
the school district says substitute
teachers will have new rules to follow
as well
we expect all of our guest teachers to
keep a log
of the schools that they attend and we
also have logs within each building
last spring covid19 was able to spread
across
long-term care facilities because many
healthcare workers worked at more than
one location
substitute teachers often work in
multiple schools too
financially i'm incented to go to as
many schools as i can if i want to make
as much money as i can that's that's the
nature of the work
there are few rules across the country
limiting the number of schools teachers
are able
to work at but in toronto sarah
boomhauer plans to work at just
one school this year still she worries
about what happens if she gets sick
or is put under quarantine as an
occasional teacher if i don't work i'm
not paid
now i'm quarantined 14 days unpaid what
is that what's the impact on my
community what's the impact on my family
my individuality i mean it's really
concerning
that's a problem echoed by alberta's
teachers union in a year where an
outbreak of covet 19 could increase the
need for teacher coverage
there is little protection available for
the substitute teachers themselves
we've talked to boards in government
about possibly putting substitutes on
contracts so that they do have access to
other leaves and benefits to protect
them and their families as well
because as it stands now boomhauer says
she just feels uneasy
with both her health and finances
vulnerable
as she heads back to class under colfid
19.
heather urex west global news calgary
the white police officer who shot a
black man in wisconsin has been
identified as officer
ruston chesky the force says a woman
called police to say her boyfriend was
at her home and wasn't supposed to be
investigators say officers tried to
arrest jacob blake and used a taser
they also say he admitted to having a
weapon a knife was found in the car
blake was shot seven times in the back
and is now paralyzed
that shooting has led to protests two
black protesters were killed last night
during demonstrations calling for
justice in the police shooting of blake
and a warning the following video is
disturbing
we're not showing you the moment when
the gunman opened fire with an assault
style
rifle as he was being chased down by
protesters police arrested a white 17
year old on homicide charges
it's believed he was among other armed
civilians who claim they were protecting
businesses
i don't need more guns on the street in
the community
when we're trying to make sure that we
keep people safe law enforcement is
trained
they're the ones who are responsible
they're the ones we have faith that will
do their jobs and make sure it gets done
a curfew is in place with more protests
expected again
tonight on sunday a white officer shot
29 year old blake in the back
multiple times leaving him paralyzed
witnesses say blake was trying to break
up a fight between
two women there was a stunning moment of
solidarity in the nba playoffs
wisconsin's team the milwaukee bucks
boycotted their game against the orlando
magic
to protest the shooting of blake the
game was supposed to start just after 4
pm local time but the bucks
never took to the floor the nba then
announced that all three playoff games
scheduled for today were postponed
outrage has spread through the league in
the days since the blake shooting
the head coach of the toronto raptors
says some of his players are so upset
and frustrated
they've talked about going home the
raptors are reportedly in talks with the
boston celtics
about boycotting their game tomorrow and
there's word the milwaukee brewers
baseball team is also postponing
tonight's game
with the cincinnati reds the toronto
police officers involved in the death of
regis krachinsky paquette will not face
charges
ontario's police watchdog says there's
no evidence the officers committed a
crime
six officers were present when the
29-year-old fell to her death in may
the special investigations unit says it
reached its decision
after interviewing the officers and 15
civilian witnesses
including korchinsky pacquette's mother
and brother her family says it's
disgusted with the results of the report
we know that they're hiding things
and they're not mentioning certain
things that happen
and it's not right it's unjust and we're
not okay with it
and we don't believe them and that's our
true beliefs
and they're saving their asses the legal
team for the family says the report is
missing key information and that the
special investigations unit misapplied
the law
they're now conducting their own
investigation and plan to release an
interim report
next week in the midst of a pandemic the
last thing anyone needs is a natural
disaster
but tonight residents of the u.s gulf
coast are in the path of hurricane laura
the category 4 storm is set to make
landfall near the texas-louisiana border
it's packing sustained winds of 220
kilometers an hour
with even higher gusts laura is set to
strike with a storm surge
so high in some places officials say it
may be
unsurvivable thousands of americans are
under mandatory evacuation orders made
even more complicated
because of the need for physical
distancing jackson proskow reports
time is running out to get ready and to
get out of the way
sheriff's office as residents along the
texas and louisiana coast are told to
leave their homes while they still can
this is scary here knowing that it's
supposed to be stronger and
still unpredictable hurricane lora a
major
hurricane is bringing catastrophic winds
and a storm surge nine meters high
sweeping up to 45 kilometers inland it
was going to stay but
when they said category 4 that was it
you're going to hear the word
unsurvivable
to uh describe the storm surge that we
are expecting
half a million people have been told to
leave immediately
don't doubt now when what no one's going
to answer okay
and you are on your own those unusually
dire warnings come in an unusually
active hurricane season
laura is one of the fastest intensifying
storms
ever recorded in the gulf of mexico with
a wind event you're going to lose
electricity the possibility of your roof
flying off your house it could be
catastrophic in every storm
even one this dangerous there are always
people willing to ride it out
we know that there's going to be an
aftermath and there's going to be a lot
of cleanup to do afterwards and
we think that it's important to stay
around if we feel safe where we're at
most are leaving in two of the states
hit hardest by the covet 19 pandemic
emergency shelters are preparing for a
double threat from the storm
and the virus we're spraying hands we're
taking temperatures
and we're keeping people social
distancing the worst of the storm will
arrive
overnight along the gulf coast they're
preparing to wake up
to disaster in laura's wake jackson
prosko global news
washington a blistering report from the
people tasked with ending
solitary confinement coming up why they
say they were blocked from doing their
job
last fall ottawa promised to phase out
solitary confinement in canadian prisons
now a government-appointed panel tasked
with making sure it happened
says it was blocked from doing its job
at every turn
it accuses the correctional service of
not providing critical data and the
minister in charge
of ignoring calls abigail beeman
explains
two years in my life was spent in
solitary the longest straight time was
about four to five months
lee chappelle knows what it's like to
spend 23 hours a day in a cell
i felt like i was in sound mind when i
went into solitary but within a month
you just start losing a lot of social
skills and upon release from solitary
it's a real challenge
adapting to even being in an institution
in mainstream
population he was supportive of the
government's move to replace solitary
confinement with structured intervention
units
which would ensure at least four hours a
day outside the cell
with two hours of meaningful human
contact he calls the latest news
unfortunate the independent advisory
panel's report is blunt
and damning very simply this panel has
not been allowed to do its work
the panel first asked for data in
november 2019.
it took six months to get some but it
was
incomplete unspecified and nearly
impossible to use
and then we were told for the first time
nine months after requesting systematic
data on the operation of the structured
intervention units
that the data do not exist in march they
reached out to public safety minister
bill blair
but never heard back in its august 14
response correctional service canada
acknowledged the information they
provided
did not yield the expected quality and
committed to monthly updates
knowing the panel's one-year term is up
the
concerns brought forward by the panel of
course are things that we're taking
seriously
i know minister blair and corrections
canada are engaging on this issue
what the report reveals is the
corrections does not feel it needs to
follow the law
how long inmates spend in their cell is
one example of data the panel requested
longtime prisoner advocate and senator
kim pate says that's exactly the kind of
information corrections needs to collect
itself the only choice we have now is to
ensure that we have external oversight
and
preferably judicial oversight pate says
if the government doesn't take action
the courts
will there are several cases underway
some in connection to colvin
19. and this week the ontario human
rights commission filed a motion to hold
that province accountable
saying it's failing to meet its legal
obligation to keep prisoners with mental
health issues out of segregation
the motion alleges ontario also failed
to implement a system to accurately
track
segregation abigail beeman global news
ottawa
an ontario woman has been arrested for
allegedly attempting to join the
so-called islamic state
halima mustafa is scheduled to appear in
court tomorrow to face two
terrorism-related charges mustafa and
her husband ikar mao
left toronto together in june 2019. they
were detained in turkey and sent back to
canada in october
mao was charged with two counts of
terrorism in december
he remains in custody hundreds of
potential closures still ahead what
canada's tv
and radio landscape could look like in
the next few years
some dramatic video of a yacht on fire
and sinking in the mediterranean sea
the vessel was carrying eight tourists
from kazakhstan along with nine crew
members
it was traveling between capri and
sardinia when the fire broke out
the coast guard called in two boats and
a helicopter to rescue
everyone on board an investigation is
underway
a dire forecast today from the canadian
association of broadcasters
dozens of private radio and tv stations
across the country could be forced to
close
falling ad revenue has been made worse
by the kova 19 pandemic
as eric sorensen reports the cab is
calling on the federal government to
change
regulations and taxation to help the
industry survive
[Music]
cjob mornings here's the headline so
tune in here weekdays
at noon local radio and tv have been a
mainstay in the lives of canadians for
decades
a source for local news and local news
makers i put that
motion forward to very city council but
as more people get news online
radio and tv advertising revenue has
plummeted and on top of that
covet 19's impact fewer people in their
cars for example listening to radio
it's take your vital to work day a new
canadian association of broadcasters
report projects over the next six months
the possible closure of 50 radio
stations
over two years that total could be up to
200 closures
for local television over the next one
to three years 40 local tv stations
could close
that's almost half the 94 local stations
in the country
the cab says up to 2 000 jobs could be
lost
it's going to be catastrophic for a
number of broadcasters
and a number of communities broadcasters
say they want new regulations especially
targeting internet giants like google
and facebook
which earn the majority of today's ad
revenue but don't pay canadian news
providers for the content
with a lot of dollars going away to
global conglomerates internet
conglomerates
that's money that's coming out of the
local infrastructure to be able to
support local media outlets in a
statement the federal government points
to dollars already committed
plus the canadian emergency wage subsidy
that is currently helping eligible
broadcasters maintain more jobs in their
structure
and ottawa is working towards
modernizing the broadcasting act
with more news on that still to come
they should be supporting innovation
they should be supporting new business
models this ryerson professor says
ottawa's help is needed in the short
term
because local news is too important to
let disappear people
need to have that service to be able to
make decisions about their life
we're seeing it during the pandemic more
than ever
and that loss is just
going to be devastating to not just the
industry but to democracy itself
broadcasters say small independent
stations in canada are most at risk
if more help is to come from ottawa the
question is whether it will come
before any radio and tv stations start
to close
eric sorensen global news toronto
up next hollywood puts its faith in
tenant will the film light the way
for moviegoers
it's showtime for canada's biggest movie
theater chain
cineplex has reopened all locations
after a six-month closure
the company reports it lost over 98
million dollars
that's a 95 drop in revenue but it could
be lifted by a tent pole
that's a showbiz term for a big budget
film that becomes a
box office hit as mike armstrong
explains there are hopes a new thriller
could be the ticket
to getting moviegoers back in the seats
here we are this isn't something he had
to do
back to the movies tom cruise is in
london filming another mission
impossible movie and wednesday took
time to see a movie he
documented his trip to catch tenet on
twitter
mask and all
[Applause]
we all believed we'd run into the
burning building
now cruz wasn't really promoting the
movie tenant but the movie
industry in general an effort to get
people back into theaters
that movie is being washed by everybody
the whole industry insiders are looking
at it
vince guzzo runs a chain of theaters in
quebec he says
tenet is the movie that will decide how
quickly the industry turns around
it was supposed to be one of the big
blockbusters of the summer
instead it's really the only one
the latest wonder woman was supposed to
come out in june it's been pushed to
october
my father cannot fight and there were
movies like mulan that
simply went straight to streaming tom
cruise's top gun was pushed from this
summer
all the way to next summer but guzzo
says he's spoken to a paramount
executive who says it could be moved up
and try to understand it depending on
how
tenet does if that movie performs
anywhere close to 50 to 75 percent of
what it would normally have performed
it's a hit now in canada theaters have
reopened
cineplex is running 100 percent of its
theaters but at reduced capacity and
with new cleaning protocols
but attracting people back to theaters
may be a challenge
according to a recent poll in the u.s
only about 24 percent of millennials
are comfortable going back to movie
theaters it's even
lower for baby boomers just 12 percent
those by the way are the same numbers
for going back to gyms
where people are sweating and breathing
heavily hasn't happened yet
well the industry is holding its breath
right now
if tenant doesn't perform well it could
mean even more big movies
push back even further at a time when a
little escape
is more than welcome mike armstrong
global news montreal
and that is global national for this
wednesday i'm robin gill
tonight your canada is co island lake in
bancroft ontario thank you for watching
and i'll see you back here tomorrow have
a great night
you